o lado pessoal do que quem fala é o da
área que seja muito em mim diz é mais um
vídeo e um estrago sic fight night at
freddy's 3 no ipp nightmare aquela noite
que vocês tanto pedem à noite o
presidente lula estava em campo sabendo
joão paulo vaz garantam a noite night
mary como você chave já no jogo foi
frenético e destreza muito tempo disse
ser difícil pra mim porque eu vou
acalmar um pouco
temos de encontrar os pregos né isso
naquela agora entregue supostamente esta
noite na primeira noite mais difícil de
todas
é o que eu acho não saiu não sei se
jamais noite assim e não vi nada depois
de ter feito o último episódio final de
sete prédios não sabe eu não visou agora
é meu colega ba
ok quero vê lá numa estátua previsível
previsível amigo não posso mexer parece
com algo e rock in rio está na
ventilação eu afirmo anda i uma reunião
inédita água tão boa desculpa
pessoalmente não joga há muito tempo mas
ficará assim até tem mais piada não é só
anunciar está muito tempo porque o jogo
já estava previsível para caraças
sinceramente não gostei muito deste
fascinante frades 31 em comparação aos
outros porque pra vc caiu falar em
previsibilidade não resultou ao autuado
e tudo e tudo porque muitas coisas já
dar erro pai a quem cometa é caneta com
a causa dessas coisas meu pai agora
chave já que uma ventilação que é onde
ela aparece mais vos a fechar esta
mentiu o sol não olhe pra mês para a
entrega é aquela coisa
nada em troca agora temos que se passou
foi que o ecotudo chato lixaram poço
perfurado em todo o estado tudo estava
uma parceria que vai acontecer aqui
cláudio em cima mas não vai subir eu sei
que ela vai subir entre psp ou subiu
subiu subiu ou não não é filho da mãe do
fogo disse mello
eu to com o estado que este jogo meu pai
e agora o que eu faço agora vou assumir
tocou eu passo atrás quando eu acho que
não consegui fazer quase estragou a
festa vai acontecer agora né
vamos levar um susto eu não vou embora
ok ok ok isso entrei muito bem e foi pra
cima afinal é um raio não começou agora
alguém em casa é cara do êxito só pra
considerar a lei osesp entregues eu acho
que as coisas só começam a aparecer
quando chegamos a uma da minerva
até lá é tudo calmo mas também a hora
passa muito rápido agora passa muito
festa se eu tocar duas vezes o áudio eo
jazz estraga meu porcaria do de de órico
lar de fones microfones que é uma
porcaria usam duas vezes e vai para o
lixo preço claro e lógico né
quer dizer o botafogo
dilma se está a inventar que depois vão
pegar o metrô e mesmo que garantem
embora ex-militares que eu ia pro sereno
e mesmo assim meu deus eu já fui eu
quando fazia tempo vai fazer troca
toc toc ou passou não vai mas 80 gente
não consegue passar esta noite como
carlos tocar aqui para que hosmany a não
estragou tudo foi time fernandão foi
também foi né hoje o código code
isso aí eu posso ir pra lá meu salto que
o áudio e não sei se tem que ficar aí eu
torço pra que
filho de uma mãe toca o álbum agora
espera hora através do qual é possível
que a agência vem lançar um rápido né
não é possível ir pela ventilação
botafogo ri não dá é possível passar
este momento é impossível sair
impossível não vou conseguir
eu vou ficar aqui até a mãe é pra passar
isto porque queria eu não sei como é que
você como funciona a aula por seu agora
duas da manhã como é que eu quero
conquistar as quatro é uma coisa que não
percebo
tive desde uma idéia até agora jogar
isto era permitir o vídeo já não vão ter
o vídeo hoje vejo o quanto todos os
prenderam em dois sítios da banda 92 e
goiás estragou tudo eu trago essa cena
eu estragar esta cena não estraga oeste
são três da manhã com as quatro
passagens emocionado eu vou fazer vídeo
o calma eu tenho percebido que não
aparece aqui por favor venham com essa
câmera por cuba 4 da manhã
eu fui bater outra vez de eventual ação
da estrada pronta agora já é nada sério
quatro da manhã meu
quatro do miami o resto ea mãe ó ataque
o gajo já tá acabou acabou minha
história vila vai parcelar em cima já
saí muito vai ter esses nunca foi a
primeira já tem jogo estranho eu não
tenho controlo deu a primeira a cabo gás
forma poderão enfrentar os pais já não
saí hoje é o frei cal e whisky apae o
bubble boy parece mudar rápido meu
parece uma lagartixa não consiga evitar
ninguém aqui a inflação rápido possível
não tá aqui pra suportar a carga este
tabu é mal feito meu
eu vou por uma câmera instalada na
câmara mas enquanto olhava para a câmera
e um passo à frente 84 não roda 4 falar
eu tenho como antecipar é que quero ir
na sala vechi filha da mãe desgraçado um
texto de caraças
acho que já fiz gosta costa
é sério isso não consegui passar agora
tipo 2011 digno kuyt cheirar mal junto
logo você precisa ter calma
8 qual o erro eu vou fazer agora agora
eu to na manhã de amanhã de manhã cedo
da manhã se voltou a subir amanhã 11 em
tamanha tu não tens uns aos 15 da manhã
às cinco da manhã não tem função tu não
tens mensal só passar o jogo cinco da
manhã
silva vai deixar meu pai sair faz tanto
bater meu primeiro é que o seu passado
pra vocês já sabem deixa o vosso like
favorito eo cinema luz meu fiquem banho
e até a próxima